well I have a log line and it's not very
good and I suppose whatever I buy you in
it and poke holes through it okay so I
just I'm hoping we can deconstruct it
it's not very clear and maybe you can
help me clean it up so a well-meaning
librarian helps a prison writing group
falling head over heels for someone
entirely outside of her circle of
friends and peer group teaching her the
meaning of true love I know it sounds
pollution but so it is it's too long is
it too confusing yeah well I don't think
it's necessarily too long if you need
that many words to convey the story then
you need that many words but but I will
say the thing that I think is a little
bit confusing about it is it felt like
it jumped from one story to another so
if I were going to help you workshop it
I would ask you who your who's your
protagonist the librarian she's she's
you know highly educated came from you
know maybe a liberal world but more of a
privileged world and she works in this
library where they have a writing group
and some of the individuals there have
been a you know incarcerated and now
they've come out and what are we
watching for sort of the bulk of the
movie are we watching her work with
writers or are we there was another part
to the logline that I've forgotten now
but was it before she fell in love there
was something else
um I think well-meaning yeah I had said
that so maybe it shows her life wanting
to be involved in like community
activism and things like I thought there
was a part about her going outside of
her circle of friends oh yeah good point
um she she no no this is great she does
and so she has very she's kind of of
this like literati you know very very
like upscale you know discussing ideas
maybe college professors and people like
that in her circle of friends well I
think that that part you can probably
leave out of the of the logline because
it sounds like the movie that you're
pitching is actually about this maybe
somewhat privileged liberal librarian
well-meaning librarian who is working
with a bunch of incarcerated writers
right so that's kind of the the main
gist of your
these that does that sound right yeah
and maybe she's imprisoned by that world
and no pun intended because she feels
like she's got to still keep in
competition with her peer group okay
that may or may not fit in the logline
so what I usually tell people is that we
want to focus on just the foundation
elements that that you need to tell your
story start there and then you can sort
of like because she chose it up to add
add color in detail if you're pitching
it but I would start with the
protagonist the story goal so that main
thing that she's trying to accomplish by
the end of the movie the main force of
antagonism or opposition and then some
indication of the stakes is usually
helpful right so that we understand why
we should care about that story so I
start with those four things and then I
will say that there's like a stealth v I
think today you can include that
sometimes makes it easier to convey the
the real sort of meat of your story
right so if just for example if her
story goal is to you know I don't know I
think he said something about win the
love of somebody is that she falls in
love with someone that's been
incarcerated and this individual is way
outside of like her social circle and
what she would consider in a mate okay
and she just can't help herself
okay if that's not the a story that
might not belong in the logline
either but so I would say that whatever
her story goal is so whether it's to you
know get this writing group published in
a national magazine or whether it's to
get oh let's go with this one
let's say that her her ultimate story
goal is she starts working with these
writers and her goal is to get funding
to keep this program going because it's
gonna be cancelled right so if that's
her ultimate story goal just putting
that in the logline
doesn't necessarily tell us what we're
watching over the course of this movie
right which is that's the entertainment
value we want to know like when we go
see this movie what are we in for so so
that v stealth stealth element that I
was talking about is sometimes the
method or the strategy that the
protagonist is going to use to achieve
that goal because sometimes that
more of an indication of what's the
actual movie that we're watching right
so if her goal is to save this writing
program you know saying a well-meaning
librarian works or a well-meaning
librarian strives to save the
incarcerated prisoners writing program
at her local prison that doesn't
actually tell us what we're watching so
if you include the method then it's
something like a well-meaning liberal
librarian begins working with
incarcerated women to put their stories
on the page in order to save the writing
program at their prison something like
that that doesn't really give us a sense
of the opposition or the conflict but it
gives you kind of a start with some of
those story elements if that makes sense
sure sure I guess and this is where I'm
not being clear is that she falls in
love it's actually a man but that is not
is not what she thought prince charming
would be and she's been looking for this
Prince Charming okay when this
individual is right here and he doesn't
take all the boxes that she thought so
it's more about her sort of journey as
being in this group
she's librarian she's sort of an expert
in her field but then she falls
head-over-heels for someone that she
never expected that she would and it
causes a backlash for her got it so
interestingly in when you read the log
line I thought that the main thrust of
the story was her work with or his work
with these incarcerated writers but the
way you're describing it now it sort of
seems like maybe the a story is really
the romance is it about okay yeah I
think it's her coming out of her shell
and being with someone that she never
thought she could fall in love okay well
so in that case I would totally change
the log line and I would say it would be
something because this then really her
work with the writers is just the set up
it's just the situation that gets her to
meet this guy essentially does that
sound right yeah that's it
so so I would say after taking a new
position working with incarcerated
writers a
well meaning but give me another
descriptive word Oh sheltered yes
sheltered like a well-meaning but
sheltered librarian falls in love with
the most unlikely I don't know the most
unlikely suitor okay um and pursues a
relationship with him even though he's
so far outside of her social circle that
I don't know something else that happens
in the story so that we get the sense
that it's a Romeo and Juliet type of
story right where there's like
incompatibility on on the surface but
they they sort of have some sort of bond
right that connects them does that yes
right so really we get the sense that in
that in that log line we want to
understand that what we're watching in
this movie is really about this
relationship between these two
mismatched people but the fact that
they're their connection there's the
strength of their connection makes this
a love story worth watching basically so
that's what we're trying to get in the
logline
right if that dies and I just realized
it it's this mirrors the movie White
Castle I think with Susan Sarandon and
James Spader oh yeah I don't think oh
it's so good yeah and so and again we're
but it's flip flop in that James Spader
is the one that's from more of the
privileged environment and Susan
Sarandon is like the single mom that's
older and she's brought to this like
party and everyone just is totally quiet
like and and just the tension in the
room and it's so yeah because because
the real main conflict of your story is
about the fact that these two you know
shouldn't have fallen in love but did
right and so it's about them trying to
make their relationship work despite all
of their differences and the
unlikeliness of their relationship is
that yeah that's it yeah so that's what
we want to get in the logline
so then if I were to clean it up because
mine is a mess and it's all over the
place just a well-meaning librarian
teachers of prison writing go so I would
probably start with the fact that she
has that position teaching prisoners
because that's that's really just the
set up you just want to get that sort of
like this is the situation that gets her
in
to this bigger situation which is that
what the movie is about right so I would
probably start with after taking a
position teaching incarcerated writers a
well-meaning but sheltered librarian
forms an unlikely relationship with the
guy from the wrong side of the tracks or
however you want to characterize him I
don't know if he's like the if he's
another prisoner or a prison warden or
whatever he's done he's done his time
and comes out and he's he's done what he
thinks to make amends okay so I would
say forms an unlikely relationship with
with a guy with an ex-con and trying to
figure out how to characterize the the
nature of that main conflict which would
be and you know they they embark on
forms an unlikely connection with a with
an ex-con and they embark on a whirlwind
romance that tests both of their
preconceived notions about love and the
way to live your life or something like
that okay yeah you'll have to switch out
those elements to be true to your story
but that's kind of like the structure of
it that I would go for that's excellent
yeah I love it and if we were to be to
come up with a title for it which I
haven't okay um where would we go with
the title to would it be someone's name
would it just be you know I don't know
that's a good question and I I dislike
titles I just like coming up with titles
but what I usually tell people is that
if you're writing a spec script be more
clear than clever in your title because
I need to be able to hear that title
again and remember what script that was
you know so a good example or a good
exercise actually is if you read the the
titles and the log lines for the scripts
on the blacklist and then put that list
away for a week and come back to it and
just read the titles see if you can
remember what log lines you know which
log lines went with which titles if you
can't then that's not a useful title to
me as a
who's trying to remember which scripts
I've read and what that script was about
when somebody wants to ask me about it
you know does that make sense it does so
you said clever should be the last thing
I mean I think cleverness in a title is
great and sometimes that can make it
catchy and that can make it you know
have a sticky quality the that will help
you remember what that script was but if
it's like for example if you're writing
a biopic about Seberg right right just
call it Seabrook so that I can remember
I see that title again I'll remember
exactly what that script was you know
okay I understand right what what and
not try to do something you know the the
French temptress neroshi
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah I don't know if
that's useful to you at all but no it is
it is and do you think with titles the
the less is more in terms of words
oh I haven't actually thought about that
and directly but I mean I guess if you
can convey what your script is about in
fewer words that's probably better I
won't say that's a hard and fast rule
but it's probably better okay thank you
for this long line by the way well I
will say that in in a title if sometimes
the sometimes you do get a title that's
long on purpose and that's what makes it
memorable you know what I mean right
three billboards out of MA like that
nobody's gonna forget when they see they
may not remember the title off the top
of their heads but when they see it they
will remember what that movie is so I
don't know I guess there's no there's no
hard and fast rules there no right
answers no wrong answers
you